you've seen him on britain's got talent
and now he's one of the best acts in
fantasy at the luxor welcome daredevil
specialist jonathan goodwin welcome to
the show ah thank you thanks for thanks
for having me i appreciate it i've heard
amazing things about you how does one
become a daredevil specialist i've
really done what i do since i was seven
years old you know i read a book about
houdini when i was a kid and i after
that i never really wanted to do
anything else and that was your whole
focus that's your life's journey
literally from from then until right
here right now and so you had some
interesting things along the way
america's got britain's got talent is
where you kind of got this america's got
talent last year i was i was a
semi-finalist on america's got talent
last year which was uh it was fun and uh
and yeah now i'm right here in vegas
performing in fantasy how do how do you
practice your tricks
everything's a little different you know
uh when you a lot of the time when
you're going to do something really
dangerous
you kind of have to get it right first
time yeah because you've got a crossbow
and arrow here yes i know there's not
there's not a massive margin for error
so a lot of practice before you actually
put anyone in harm's way well we're very
excited because you're gonna do a trick
for us today i am playing we've got
mariah you're she's in the show lovely
mariah here yeah i'm gonna step back
here what are you going to do for us
today
it has to do with this blindfold that
she's making a piece of metal do you
want to check that out and make sure i
fold it up you can't see through it
can't see you're putting this on yeah so
i'm going to try and hit a target with
the crossbow not by not by seeing it but
by hearing it okay okay sure sound like
fun yeah i can't see anything out of
that ah blindfolded
we'll give it a go uh so mariah has a
balloon
he's going to hold that above her head
and i'm going to load this crossbow
loading it blindfold
alrighty
lovely mariah mariah i love you in the
show you're fantastic okay
all righty here we go
in your own time
[Applause]
wow beautiful
this is stunning you can catch jonathan
goodwin as part of fantasy over at the
luxor hotel and casino thank you so much
oh you're welcome wow